yeah never a dull moment
I would like to go and eat something and
relax a little bit
this has been a whole tense thing I'm
always tense getting to stuff because I
want to make sure like it happens you
know I get a little type-a about it and
I just wanna relax
I feel good had a great time in there
they're really invigorating when you
come out of these things you just feel
really calm
Washington's car Scott has a cleanest
car I've ever seen
all right
I eat this is um this is all gonna be
washed again I'm gonna get to this don't
worry about it I'm gonna wash this
she's hungry here we go
there we go coffee so funny cuz we
started doing these day in the life
think we didn't even know Morgan
Spurlock doesn't we just found that out
a very special day for me I get to go
and I get to sit on the press around
table
Morgan Spurlock and Holly from the
comic-con documentary
she's just so awesome and I highly
recommend it really
I've never been to comic-con but um I'd
like to go this year even if it's just
for two hours to still walk around
coffee is very important in the morning
although I wouldn't say I'm a morning
person I like to be up early when I do
get up early I feel really good about
myself I feel like that I know my Tommy
I've done something important
all right now it's a feed a black hat
outside it's a cat that um guess he's a
stray
she's been around for about six months
he's gotten in some nasty fights
actually I think he got in a fight
underneath the house there's like a
possum and I started stomping on the
floor you know stop I think they both
got freaked it out he's hoping they ran
away
sometimes he
he hears me he'll come out food at
forums with the other neighborhood so
they see if he makes an appearance he's
kind of a late was close to
we're gonna eat once I leave
I have done my coffee spawning the right
balance with the carpet too much and I'm
jittery this chair
not have to do anything
so probably take a few vitamins and I
like to go for a walk a few blocks down
is a nice area to walk and I like to go
there it clears my head
and it just I don't know it sets the
right tone to the day when I don't get a
chance to walk
I just feel sluggish and I feel just
just not right and that walk really hurt
one guy out there the other day he's
like this is medicine and he's right it
is it's medicine
I feel great
this is really
just amazing these beautiful
she was like all I need right here but I
know it's not when you boil it down
I feel good I have to
get ready we're running out of time but
I wanted to get it quits walking
it just helps me I just feel better
being out here
it just feels clean it just feels
I doubt it all your troubles just seem
so small once you come out
things are really a big deal and then
you get home and then the little things
our Father but this
this is where it's all right here
yeah this is what I tried to do every
day
which helps
and I get really nervous leaving because
I always feel like I've forgotten
something and I get I like things to be
just right they're not right III
blending myself because um I should have
had it all prepared I'm sort of a
planner but I like I like to be around
more spontaneous people it's weird
that's weird how that works I don't like
to be around other planners my severe
another's spontaneous fun artistic types
and maybe that's because I've always had
to plan and look out for myself so I've
never had that luxury of just relaxing
and being able to be like oh cool yeah
if it works out great because I've
always had to make sure my ducts were in
a row it's basically it was just me to
rely on so anyway I'm stressed right now
I'm trying to get ready and I have a few
minutes before I need to be out the door
luckily I've gotten gas already and
but we got a little bit of a detour your
syllabus
a lot of people in LA I don't know about
this part of LA
dogs all dressed up
it's kind of the thing in LA is just
like just get there first because you
don't know what's gonna be there like if
the roads gonna be diverted or there's
going to be a huge traffic jam
this is what I'm referring to you never
know
it's pretty cool I love taking the train
something very romantic about this is
what I want to be doing I want to be
driving
in LA traffic to go see Morgan Spurlock
and one of the stars was film Holly for
every night this is
this is I love like hearing the behind
the six stories and I love just being in
a room where everybody's excited and no
I'm not being paid for this but I feel
like I'm on the right path I feel like
this is what I'm supposed to be doing
if it means that I have to take
part-time jobs that
don't really fulfill me just so that I
can get a chance to have a day off like
this do this then I guess it's worth it
life is really really too short to just
spend it not doing what you love and I
think a lot of us think that Oh get the
right job get that title just be on that
path save up we don't even know if we're
gonna live to that point where we can
come to enjoy it why not live for it now
and that's the part I struggle with
because sometimes the now isn't so fun
when you're doing some of these other
jobs that you're not totally into
but this is today feels good today it
feels like I'm meant to do this
I want to wake up and be happy to wake
up and today was one of those days
I want to wake up and feel like good
instead of this nying like this isn't
what I want and time is time is ticking
we're at the Luxe Hotel and by
it's in LA
restrooms
Nate you to need money so we're here in
the ballet our room
very comfortable it's a little early
it's 115 or so so we have some time
before you go in for the interview I'm
just gonna look over the press notes
so it's quarter to two and I think I'm
gonna go ahead on in I'm seeing a lot of
other press people go in there and I'm
starting to feel like the kid that sees
everybody going on a ride at Disneyland
and they can't go on did you have any
expectation you know I just want to see
what it's like in there sometimes it's
easy to ask questions and then other
times it's better to just be more of an
observer so depends on how aggressive
Oh
Tony Parker
Morgan and Holly came in first and they
had great energy and I asked the
question that you wanted me to ask and
that was that how things changed for you
are you working harder now Morgan then
you first were in like 2004 with Super
Size Me and he said well yeah I mean now
people return my calls it didn't happen
in the beginning so I thought that was a
very valid point but now he's able to
parlay all this and run with it
whereas before he kind of deals what we
all deal with you and I deal with is
that we don't always get calls returned
also asked Holly you know how are things
for you now I mean the movie hasn't even
come out yet but her audition tape on
YouTube has thousands of hits and she
said it's been
a little overwhelming but wonderful and
that she has a ton of offers from people
that she's not even able to keep up with
so I thought that was interesting what
what else you have to do when you get
home well I want to get this footage in
this you know import it and help you
with the video have stuff to do on the
site to upload some articles and various
things and answer emails and then
I'm doing my own day in the life video
on someone else so I've been editing
that slowly but surely
I like the way it's coming along
and then also have to prepare for the
show which is coming up on Sunday but
usually around Thursdays is when the
pace picks up for us I would say
probably Monday
once we get to show up is the only kind
of supposed to downtime we have because
things pick up excuse me things pick up
pretty quickly after that
and so we have to prepare the show most
of the questions right I just have to
kind of format it and confirm with the
guests
and he's flying in his brother up flying
into LA
hopefully everything's good to go if not
we putting out a Facebook post and
coming up with some new questions
it's 4:30 right now we are still
maneuvering our way home streets of Los
Angeles
it's been an extremely productive day
I'm a little my Energy's pretty low
right now but I feel good I feel like we
got a great experience under our belt
and I'm really happy really grateful for
the opportunity
I urge everyone to see the film
it just really brings you into that
whole world of comic-con and it just
shows you how people that may not be
accepted other places you know in like
societies you know they're accepted
there and and they they're amongst each
other and although there might be you
know some turbulent things that happen
every once in a while it's a great place
to go so I'm hoping to go to comic-con
for the first time after seeing this
film it makes me want to go
today could have been more productive if
we were able to shoot
you know get video footage but we
weren't so there was a point where
Morgan and Holly were having lunch but
we didn't want to film that we just you
know that
I didn't want to invade their privacy so
that's the only way that I wish I could
have captured what I have on audio on
video but I'm still very happy
it seems excited thank you
so we're back home it's 626 and it looks
like we've gotten some article
submissions sent to us so I'm gonna get
those up now and I love it when articles
come in because then I can you know
formulate it and make it look nice and
put it on the site and then we'll tweet
it out and Dave will be working on the
audio portion he's taking it from the
voice recorder and then he's gonna put
it into Final Cut Pro and then we'll get
that going and then hopefully soon edit
our own version of day-in-the-life
inspired by Morgan Spurlock even though
we didn't know that he was doing them
until we started doing ours so they were
must have been reading his mind or
something